do not need to re thank you
now maybe your mic will work so we don't
need to refer to all the areas that say
no
change so i'll ask uh
representative oberger who who does the
first
thank you mr chairman i'm actually going
to move
that we exceed to the senate for
category one changes i will speak to
that briefly if i get a second
tracie representative will second that
if i might speak to this briefly i'm
wearing a red dress
i mean a green dress because i'm always
i'm jealous of the senate you always
have more money than we have
we're always facing smaller revenues and
most of these changes that you guys made
were things that we pushed just because
we were short of money
uh there were changes to the department
of information technology that needed to
be done
some of that relates to the creation of
the new department of energy
that's page one if you look at page two
you're looking at admin services
we concur with all of those changes the
new hampshire housing board
we do those the office of the
child advocate funds a full legal time
aid and an
assistant that we did not have money for
department of revenue administration
you actually removed two audit positions
that we had in
because we needed the revenue from the
additional audit positions we're okay
with that
debt service is something that had to to
you look at the total changes
they amounted to for the biennium
hundred and sixty one thousand dollars
we are in i'm going to do it page by
page and i just did those page by page
well we need a motion on each page is
what i want to do
i move category one
entirely the whole category one which
goes i did
no it ends on page four and i just went
page by page through all of those
all right correct page one through four
correct are you up to page four yeah
yes damn all right
that was your motion it was seconded by
represent that we exceed to the senate
position
on all this uh section one
all members of the house in favor raise
and over to the center all members of
the senate
in favor raise your hand okay
that takes care of four pages thank you
division one agencies
the judicial branch and the department
of justice
which moves on to page
six the department of military affairs
we already moved they were
zero department of agriculture
no change we've now moved to page
seven
we are in agreement there was a
movement of a position in the insurance
department
the liquor commission restored 20
enforcement positions
towards the bottom and then we have
adjustments to the newly created
department of energy on page eight
in the department corrections on page
nine
we restore a position that we did not
have funding for
which brings us to the bottom of page 10
because the summary funds
are on 9 and 10 and these changes
amount to two million one hundred eight
thousand dollars and the house succeeds
to the senate position
i will move that motion second
motion in a second for those pages that
discussion thank you i'm not going to
vote no on this but i just want to
mention that i think we
lost an opportunity by not funding any
of the teacher positions at the
department of corrections
because most of these inmates are going
to get out and
they'll be more successful if they're
educated
and career worthy if i could respond to
that
yes we we funded
when the budget came to us the governor
had cut six million dollars in the
department of corrections for
education and training the house
replaced that with five million dollars
so we funded the majority of those
teachers
i also at the time talked to
commissioner helen hanks now that we
have
newer prisons with more computer
technology
many of the things that our prisoners do
could be done
with the offerings through v-lacs one of
our charter schools that's virtual
that now does sixth grade seventh grade
eighth grade
up through high school and so she felt
she could
with the positions that were funded
because there were only i think three
positions unfunded but the remainder
were funded
she could use the new technology with
for the question thank you when the
commissioner
came to the senate she requested
us to restore funding for six positions
that were unfunded
two of which were filled so we will be
eliminating two active
the commissioner told me that those
positions were now vacant
i don't know where they were when she
came to you i just called in
last week and asked her if we had
managed to fund all her field positions
and everything else was
vacant and she did tell me yes so
senator rosenwald i don't know what she
said in the senate i was not there that
day
i did double check with her
well we did make an important change
after a 300 page
audit on the liquor commission
enforcement
we chose to have those people not
be badged and you restored it were you
convinced that
they had had proper attention to that
uh i'll speak for me personally uh
we did receive a lot of feedback from
from businesses who
who felt it was beneficial to uh
continue to have these positions
and uh understanding uh
that their audit was not
satisfactory uh i believe that notice
has been given
that uh i would expect them to do what
they're supposed to do uh
and i would be prepared in two years
from now if we come back and see the
same things we're seeing this year
uh to defund those positions thank you
further discussion seeing none
we have a motion we have a motion and a
second to
uh for the house members to accede
to those items for section two
all the house members in favor raise
and senate senate members paper raise
your hand
okay mr chairman division one has two
more pages pages 15 and 16
if everybody could turn to those pages
we'll skip over page 10.
yes those belong to division two and i'm
sure karen will do a wonderful job with
that
all right we'll stick with the pages and
and go to division two
representative umberger no
this is still 15 and 16 it's division
one no
but i want to i want to go in the order
of the pages okay keep myself from being
confused
all right let's start with page 11 and
then when we get to page 15 we'll do
page 15.
so representative umberger
starting on page 11. uh
thank you mr chairman um
i would move that we aced to the senate
for what they have done on safety
safety had come in and asked for these
positions
from the house and um
we were lucky if we were able to
do things that they needed to be done
but we did not have the
financial availability to
uh add these positions so
i feel that these were the things they
wanted
and needed i mean not just wanted but
needed
operate safety okay
a motion in a second for the house to
exceed
on the safety issues in
hb1 further discussion
seeing none of members of the house in
members of the senate in favor raise
your hand
okay
that brings us to page 15 mr chairman
and we'll go back to representative ober
i would move to exceed to the senate on
pages 15
and 16. second
motion motion in a second to exceed
to the senate position on pages 15 and
16 which deal with
business and economic affairs department
of natural cultural resources department
and the peace development authority
which has no change
so at the top of the page again this is
a department of energy
change some of the staff went from osi
to the department of energy or bea and
this
one moves one more staff member from
department of energy into bea
the second line restores funding for a
position we did not have money to fund
they added funding additional funding
for the small business development
center
which again we did not have the money
they added money to
tourism tourism development fund
training funds and they also funded the
cost associated with relocating
the osi staff from osi which is
going away to bea
when you look at natural and cultural
resources
they again restored some money for
positions we did not have
they reduced the funding in class 27
department of environmental services
called me after the budget had been
approved
and asked for the replacement mercury
analyzer that you see
i told them to go to the senate that we
would approve but we had already made
the
things the senate has added money to the
lakes restoration fund
and to circular maintenance and as you
see at the bottom
the total fund change is three million
five hundred sixty one thousand
hundred and twenty dollars we are in
total agreement
okay any further discussion seeing none
house members in favor of the motion
raise your hands senate members in favor
raise your hand okay
to department of transportation
thank you mr chairman um i would move
that the house a seed to the senate
position
second okay with department of
transportation
the motion is for the house members to
exceed to the senate position
is there any further discussion i just
want to say thank you
for the things that they were able to do
that i was not
it's good that we were able to restore
these positions for you
we were in a tight budget situation with
the
revenue situation we were given when we
started our budget
so any further discussion
seeing none house members in favor of
senate members in favor of the motion
transportation
moving on to health and human services
representative edwards uh thank you mr
chair
um i i'd like to do this a little bit
differently than the my predecessors
have just
done this um i uh
i'd like to start on on page 20
and and just uh note a few things and
and ask some questions about
the the bigger items uh for for example
uh the senate has agreed with us that
the sununu center
ought to be closed in the coming budget
uh you
allocate an additional eight months for
for that work to be done
and you've you've changed how the
funding looks
you've done nine million dollars per
fiscal year
and we put money in the first year and
none in the
in the second so i'm i'm
i would just like to hear uh your
thought
on uh why the extra eight months and
and what the sense of commitment is on
the part of the senate
i think we were all in agreement uh with
the closure of it
uh what we needed to do was to provide
the appropriate time for things to
to get in place uh to to transfer it
over
to closure and we set the budget up
accordingly
thank you for that and and then are you
anticipating
any uh reviews uh by the legislature
over the coming 20 months or so to
i don't recall that we talked about
that but but i would expect that uh if
we set in place a closure date
that uh someone the department
or the legislature or both uh could
monit monitor it
uh certainly that uh could be brought
forward in legislation
thank you um
one of your questions representative
edward was about the spend
on and and why we put the nine or nine
and a half million dollars in each year
and looking at the historical dollar
amounts especially
in 2020 um and looking back to
the work that the um i know that the
house has done
on this issue and looking at what
actually needs to be spent
for the for the number of children at
the sununu services center we felt that
was
a reasonable number to put in for the
budget as far as looking
at how it's going to be going forward
the commission that was put in
hb2 i believe can monitor the
the closure and and the timeline and how
thank you for that um
i would like to make a motion then uh
to a seed to the senate physician but i
would like to be able to go from um
from rows one to row
48 row 48 ends on page 23
and then because i i have some
okay a motion and a second that the
house exceed
to the senate position on
on the health and human services so that
would be
page 20 through 23 was it
9 48 on on page 23. yes sir thank you
so any further discussion in those areas
representative rosenwald do you want to
have any further discussion
by senator roosevelt excuse me
you must want your title right um
i'm not comfortable with the
amount of money on line 34
which is the um
sorry line 22 the housing shelter
program
on page 20. um not only does this
not include the
prioritized need for that the department
asked for to increase the shelter
reimbursement rate and we've had
discussions about
how we might appropriate federal funds
through fiscal i spoke with the
commissioner just
like an hour ago and she said the
department still
did not have firm plans for
how to fund or what to put in
and i i think it's more emergent than
just letting it go but in
addition the amount of money contained
within this
line when we did add three million
dollars
that's for our separate programs
is actually a cut of 862
dollars versus the current biennium and
um i think we're just going to be in
greater trouble with the homeless
problem that we have if we
don't even bring the
next biennium up to where we've been
this
budget so so i'm not able to support
this motion
senator hennessey thank you uh
chairman weiler i have a question for
the lba
thank you can you talk to us about this
line
and if this 1.5 per fiscal year
is an improvement over the last biennium
or if it's if there's still a cut in
there somehow
okay i can turn this over to uh kevin
who looked into that class line
so to be clear we're talking about line
sure and i'm looking up this accounting
unit now i believe with the addition of
the 1.5 million
it is an increase over the previous
biennium
um what the department had stated though
was that there was a contract line
in there that was artificially low
because of the way fiscal 21 was
calculated so that's what senator
rosenwald is referencing
the overall amount in that accounting
unit though for general funds is higher
senator rosenwald thank you a question
for the lba
um so the shelter contract line
isn't that lower if you were
fast
so yes actually if you look at class 102
which is where the funding would go and
which is where the senate added 1.5
million
there is a reduction in 2223 from the
2021 budget
i believe that's a reallocation of funds
from from class line 102 to class 74
because there's a big increase in 74.
so i may in order to give you a
definitive answer i may need to check in
with the department on this but yes if
you're looking at class 102 in isolation
that is lower in 2223 than it was in
senator hennessey thank you just to
follow up on that can for those
of people listening can you just explain
what class 74 is
is that the contracts line
class 24 is grants for public assistance
and relief
uh so there was a significant increase
in that class line
from the last biennium and a significant
decrease in class 102 contracts for
mr chair for discussion purposes we saw
that a lot
in dhhs's budget where they switched
between those two class lines over this
biennium
so this is not unusual
anything further on discussion we have a
motion to accept
up through line or up for you
up through line 48 true line 48.
house members um voting for the amen
senate members in favor of the motion
all right motion passes
okay moving on representative edwards uh
thank you mr chair
um i'd like to ask the senate about
line 50 the tobacco prevention and
secession
number i i don't recall this
in the governor's budget i do recall
hearing about it in division iii and a
request for us to add it
and i remember our conversation around
this
was that the testimony
did not indicate that there was any uh
evidence that this money was actually uh
being effective in terms of uh reducing
the rate at which
uh people are smoking in our society
and and so because we we couldn't find
any evidence
um to support it we we didn't
we didn't support this program and and
i'm just curious
um what what the what the thought
process is of
adding this money back from what the
house had
thank you representative for the
question um
as we as we went through particularly
the hhs budget
we recognized that there were multiple
areas that we really didn't know if they
were being effective or not
so one of the things that we were trying
to do was to address the immediate needs
secondly we are trying to address uh
the root cause of some of those things
so so recognizing that tobacco was one
fell into that category where we really
didn't
have all the information we needed um we
didn't want to
vacate it and just let it run but
i know at least it's my intent over the
next
year and a half to be monitoring these
programs
so that as we go into the next biennium
we know what's working and not working
and i raise that question numerous times
uh during the presentation by hhs
as to how they define success in a
program so this this is something that i
would be following through on the
tobacco as well
uh thank you very much for that uh that
response i i can relate to that um
if if i may um mr chair i
i would like to drop down to line 63
and just just note that on line 63 and
64.
i just got a text mr chair that we're
are we failing to live stream
technicians
yes all right do we need to stop
karen and i probably knew what was
coming so we spent hours with our
buckets
going over making sure we had everything
i think we're live now mike or we lost
money might change
we are not in a recess we are in a break
let me make that clear recesses require
us to
all right i guess we're waiting for the
youtube
section to be restored but we are
as we are on break waiting to
degrees
is
discussions
actually
is
i'm always picky about these because
because i don't get them because they
no one can no one will get on the
contract
thanks
okay
you